Simon sinek is with me here in the
studio and I am super excited to
announce you hello Simon good afternoon
for you good evening for us here in the
Netherlands a very warm welcome I know
you've been to Amsterdam and to the
Netherlands before so I'm hoping that
you might consider traveling again at
some point
yeah of course I mean I I love it there
I've been all over the country I know I
saw that on on previous posts that that
you sent out like in a pre-pandemic
world which we can barely imagine at
this point I was wondering about that if
you had been here we could have gone
back to like shaking hands and we're
meeting virtually of course but you said
at the beginning of the pandemic when we
get through this every handshake and hug
will mean so much more and I was
wondering do they do you feel that do we
have the capacity to really learn
through a crisis like this
I mean never let a good crisis go to
waste for sure
um I I think that I I think so I mean
the the times that I've gone to uh some
small conferences or dinner parties
somebody always says how special it
feels
um my fear is that um we'll forget we'll
go back to the way things were and take
things for granted so I think first and
foremost we have to remember how special
human contact is and and try and keep it
a front of mind for the rest of our
lives I hope absolutely you said even
that you grew up during the pandemic
that you reached a sense of maturity
that you hadn't before can you please
explain
I mean sure the it was a time of
self-reflection you know
um there was at the beginning there was
a lot of fear there's a lot of anxiety
um uh I uh like many got to spend a lot
of time with my family you know I
traveled a lot less and
um and that rat race that being on that
hamster wheel that that so many of us
are on all the time
um I got to step off it for a while and
you know a lot there was a lot of
self-reflection and I think dealing with
pivoting my business and having to make
some extremely excruciating and
difficult decisions
um and working
um so intensely I I do feel like I grew
up I think there was uh you know I sort
of finally became an adult yeah I heard
you say that at some point I thought it
was so fascinating because before
already telling
telling world how to run their
businesses and and then you're basically
doing that as a child
I mean sure I had I I I I sort of
approached the world of a childlike
mentality for sure
um and I think uh uh it is you know I
don't know I don't know how to put it
you know I feel I feel more mature I
don't know if that's better or worse but
that's just how I feel yeah did you lose
something through maturing
um that's a great question
um I hope not I hope I built upon rather
than lust you know I think that maturing
is not about letting go of of childlike
qualities but by adding to them right
and so I think uh I I I like to think of
it as additive
um yeah thank you thank you for that
beautiful answer so let's talk
leadership uh first to like roll it all
the way back what's the difference
between an infinite and a finite mindset
sure so this was a definition put
forward in the mid-1980s by a remarkable
uh thinker uh Theologian and philosopher
by the name of Dr James karst and he
defined these two types of games finite
games and infinite games a finite game
is defined as known players fixed rules
and an agreed upon objective football
for example there's always a beginning
middle and an end and if there's a
winner necessarily there have to be
losers then you have infinite games
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players which means you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are and any new player can join
at any time the rules are changeable
which means that every player can play
however they want and the objective is
to perpetuate the game to stay in the
game as long as possible turns out we
are players in infinite games every day
of Our Lives for example there's no such
thing as winning global politics there's
no such thing as
a winning education you can come in
first for the finite amount of time
you're at school but nobody wins
learning or wins education and there's
definitely no such thing as winning
business right business as an infinite
game so there's it's more the approach
of a Continuum instead instead of
something with a clear end goal so you
mentioned that someone with an infinite
mindset understands the importance of
adapting to things instead of repeating
whatever has worked in the past so what
differentiates Leaders with this
infinite versus finite mindset
so finite-minded leaders tend to rely on
what's worked in the past
um the tried and true the business model
what got us here will get us there right
um uh where the infinite-minded leader
recognizes that the world changes
technology changes culture changes
tastes change politics change
um and necessarily a business has to
change a business is an evolving uh
entity
um and an infinite-minded leader
recognizes that what got us here won't
necessarily get us there and they're
willing to be open-minded about almost
anything that their business does yeah
and then that also involves a
self-centered approach in the good sense
of the word that you really focus on
your
own state of focusing very much on the
competition I think that is something
that you found right can you name some
examples of that
well uh I mean you're talking about a
new idea that I proposed called a worthy
rivalry
um you know in a in a game of football
in a finite game we have a competitor
and a competitor is there to be beaten
that is that is the that is the
relationship
um but in in business as I said before
it's an infinite game
um there's no such thing as winning in
business and so viewing the other
players in the game as competitors to be
beaten is silly because
how do you know who's won like it no we
don't agree on the metrics and we don't
agree on the time frames we don't even
agree on the objectives you know is it
most profitable is it biggest market
share is it I mean who knows what uh and
again no no agreed upon time frame so to
say we are trying to beat our competitor
literally is is ridiculous
um and so the infinite-minded leader
um instead views the other players as
Rivals some of which are worthy of
comparison and a worthy rival is another
player in the game who does one or many
things better than you their strengths
reveal to you your weaknesses and that
is an opportunity to improve yourself
because in the infinite game the
ultimate competitor is yourself and the
goal is a game of self-improvement and
as you said become fixated on figuring
out new ways to advance our cause rather
than beat our competition right and uh
have you seen that play out really well
in some companies like they really
mastered this type of approach
yeah I mean some companies have the ones
that are very Mission focused quite
frankly
um uh um you know what I love about you
know I know Apple you sort of we
sometimes get tired of using them as an
example but especially in the Steve Jobs
days they were so good at it
um and if you remember they would
articulate who their worthy rival was
you know first it was IBM big blue which
was the status quo that they were trying
to uh go up against and then sort of IBM
sort of was less of an issue and then it
became Microsoft hi I'm a Mac I'm a PC
if you remember the old TV ads
um and now it's sort of Google and
Facebook
um and I really appreciate that
um and uh the the companies that are
more infinite minded they don't feel
threatened by the other uh uh other
players in the game but rather inspired
by them and pushed by them they are like
like in a running race you know the
other the other people push us to run
faster yeah yeah I was just thinking of
my own city of Utrecht where I live a
lot of new restaurants have opened up
that are all trying to get a Michelin
star we haven't had much of a culinary
tradition in our city for over a decade
and now all of a sudden there are three
restaurants that are really
outperforming and so they're they're
trying to ask these restaurant owners
like aren't you afraid that the other
ones get the Michelin star first and
they're like no this is great because
we're creating this environment where
all of us are trying really hard and
it's gonna like raise the whole the
whole game is that kind of what it is
right it's good for everyone
thank you for playing for the they're
playing for the good of the game which
is what we do in the infinite game we
play for the good of the game and that
is exactly what they're trying to do
they're trying to make Utrecht into a
into a restaurant and culinary City that
people will travel to first to eat and
they are one of those players yeah
that's a perfect example great well if
you come back to the Netherlands I'd
love to take you out to the one they got
the first Michelin star or any other one
would be great well we have a room full
of entrepreneurs and and Business
Leaders change makers they are of course
also very interested in the metrics uh
side of things so what can you what what
convincing argument is there to to see
beyond this day-to-day approach and and
really incorporate the the in fight the
the the through line in all of your
business
so the infinite game is not the absence
of finite games there's nothing wrong
with metrics metrics are good and very
important without metrics how do we know
how far or how fast we're going you know
even if we run a marathon we still need
markers to tell us you know what
distance we've covered
um metrics are extremely important the
whole point of an infinite mindset is
not the absence of the metrics it's
recognizing that metrics are not the
end-all be-all and instead of being
obsessed with what the year is what the
year or the quarter is but rather be
more of success with trending you know
in other words are we trending towards
uh uh growth are we you know we trending
in Decline and it doesn't matter as much
if we hit some arbitrary number and some
arbitrary date the obsession and the
infinite mindset is is the overall trend
yeah okay so the the overall trend is is
that through line that you want to keep
an eye out John if we go back back uh to
your big why question I love that Ted
Talk by the way I thought still like am
I really looking at the right one is
this the the infamous super famous Ted
talk because it looks kind of crappy
it's not either you ever flip over it's
it's not like a TED talk like super
smooth or anything it's just that your
idea was so good that it shook the world
why was the world sorry go ahead
I mean you're right I mean I think this
is proof that sometimes the content is
more important than than the way it's
recorded or the uh or how pretty it is
um you know it's it's true you know
whenever people get nervous giving a
presentation I always try and remind
them that my video quality was terrible
my microphone broke in the middle of my
talk you know and yet it still went out
to be the second most watched Ted Talk
of all time which is insane and it's
proof that um the idea really does
matter and people care much more about
the idea than they do
um uh uh about um how pretty it is
right yeah if you can have both that's
great but if you're gonna have to
sacrifice one sacrifice pretty over over
quality well now you have it all why um
why is is now this moment in history the
right time for this Theory why did it
launch because maybe you know people
thought of these things before but why
is now the time for this why question
what's so fascinating is that that talk
came out I'm you know in in 2009 and
I've been giving that talk for 15 years
so when you talk about now it's been you
know it takes it takes a long time for
these things
exactly I I think there's there's two
parts to it which is um you know for
quite a long time you know through the
80s 90s and and especially 2000s as well
um we were very very finite minded in
our approach to business
um we saw the rise of using mass layouts
we saw the rise of shareholder Supremacy
all of these things didn't really exist
prior to the 80s and 90s and they really
became popularized and we saw we started
to see an obsession with with
short-sightedness and it it came at a
cost it came across to our personal
health the longevity of a company the
quality of the culture
um how we felt about going to work and
it you know over the long run that had
massive implications for business as
well decline of uh loyalty amongst
employees also decline of innovation we
saw a decline of innovation over the
past few years as well
so so it had it comes at a cost not to
mention our mental health right and uh
so I think two two things were at play
why that that talk mattered number one
was I think we were starting to feel the
impact of that that finite business
model and we're looking for Alternatives
and I offered an explanation the other
reason is I took something that was
important but it sounded you know a
little bit hippie you know when I
purpose at work sounded so hippie back
then and I found a language I talked
talked about why that and grounded it in
the tenets of biology uh and I found a
language that made those who needed to
listen listen I wasn't just preaching to
the converted and I think that's one of
the the important things there was
really about language yeah yeah that
that three-legged stool right that's the
that's that that idea of feeling
thinking and behavior should all work
together and the why then sits on on top
of it and it's really the beholder of
all of that um so you are calling out
that to for for leaders to apply deep
listening because it is important for
them can you just explain to me why that
is so important
well I think uh active listening deep
listening whatever you want to call it
um which is where we listen for meaning
uh rather than just listening to words I
think is one of the essential components
of good leadership
um you know ultimately uh you know
people want to feel seen and they want
to feel heard
um and good leaders are able to make
people feel seen and heard it's the same
as good customer service quite Frank you
know if you look at a customer
relationship we you know customers don't
necessarily
um uh want to have everything go their
way that's not what good customer
service is customers want to feel like
you actually care about helping them
solve a problem even if you can't yeah
and it's the same thing you know whether
at work or whether we're the customer we
want to feel like somebody actually
cares about us as a human being and one
of those things is learning how to
listen yeah do you feel that because
covid in that sense is a great uh has
been a great test case because a lot of
companies had really Incorporated their
their their purpose and the why and they
thought well you know now we've got it
all figured out but the true test has
really come in many ways during covet
like do people really feel that their
companies are really living what they're
saying right because now you see a lot
of people resigning from their job the
great resigning you even call it right
is that yeah how do you see that
yeah I mean the great resignation is a
real thing and you know people are
leaving for multiple reasons some to
follow their dreams but I think it's
also an indictment on on corporate
cultures for the most part you know
um which is a lot of companies that just
got away with allowing the corporate
cultures to be fine you know how's your
job it's fine you know they got away
with that for decades
um because the the Power Balance was was
tilted way towards the company
um and I think one of the things that
kova did it made us less afraid of the
unknown a lot of people lost their jobs
a lot of people were put on temporary
furloughs and a lot of people just lived
in fear and yet we got
um through covid and we survived we we
are here to we are here you know
um and uh and I think we became less
afraid so you know before where the
unknown was scarier than fine I'll just
make do with fine now the unknown is
just a lot less scarier and I'm willing
to take a risk to find something where
I'd rather be happy at work so I think I
think I think companies um I you know I
think that's it's a shot across the bow
um and it's it's a rebalancing of of
power dynamics you know where too long
it was tilted towards the company it
made you know the great designation is
tilted the other way and it'll it'll
come back and find a proper balance but
I think leaders that are taking
themselves on and taking on their
cultures I think will ultimately
um see the see that as a competitive
benefit in the in the future competitive
advantage in the future right because
what what will that do too because it's
quite we got some questions too about
this
um how do you ensure that your culture
continues to uh or hiring new staff is
extra extraordinarily uh challenging
these days it's hard to find talents
hard to keep them what is your advice
well again you know not just talking
about their pay and their benefits which
is usually how we tempt people but
talking about how what programs we have
inside our companies that will help them
grow you know what we expect of them do
we expect them to take themselves on and
become better versions of themselves and
we will be there to support them and
help them do we give training to uh to
our leaders and Future Leaders how to
listen how to have difficult
conversations how to give and receive
feedback um how to have an effective
confrontation or even giving that kind
of training to the people that we're
going to put in a leadership position
um and I think we need to advertise
those things uh to people who want to
join our companies to say that just as
we expect you to take yourself on we're
taking ourself on and this is a game of
constant Improvement we're not perfect
but we are trying and striving to be a
better version of ourselves right so
acknowledging that you're not perfect
and really embracing that that fear of
the unknown that we have now all come to
live with
um makes does that make for a more
vulnerable leaders too
well that word scares a lot of uh people
in leadership positions I know that's
why I used it and maybe the whole room
is full of scared people now oh my God
they're gonna talk vulnerability right
vulnerable sounds weak right
um but vulnerability simply is the
expression of of Doubt or uncertainty
sometimes you know saying I don't know
is vulnerable right
um saying this is going to be difficult
it's vulnerable I think a lot of leaders
pretend they have all the answers or
pretend that they have no no uncertainty
and of course that's nonsense because we
all have uncertainty we all have doubt
um
um now you can't come to work and you
know go oh my God the whole thing's
gonna going to crash you know that's
just uh an equally unrealistic
um but uh you know when when you have a
company that allows for people to feel
vulnerable that means someone can raise
their hand and say
um I made a mistake or I need help or I
don't understand or I'm having trouble
at home and it's affecting my work or
I'm scared
um without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather they say it with
confidence that someone will rush to
support them and the way that you
encourage that kind of culture is that
the leaders have to set the example and
so during covid you know when I was
having when I was struggling as we all
went through a period of really of
mental struggle I said to my team I'm
off my game I'm really I'm struggling
you know it's getting to me and I just
need your help and your patience to to
that I may be pretty slow to respond and
not of it very effective for now you
know and I said that and that allowed
other people to speak up so that we
could be there for them but if I if I
pretended that everything was fine that
everything was good the whole time then
everybody's going to pretend
everything's fine and everything's good
and then how can we be there to support
each other until they crash so um I
think vulnerability is is is just being
a little more open and the irony is is
it takes tremendous courage and strength
to express vulnerability it's actually
strong to be vulnerable it actually is
very weak to pretend that everything's
fine yeah were you were are you already
more adult when you were ready to
acknowledge that to your team
uh yeah I think so um I'd learned that
lesson uh before yeah
um yeah so it is important to to express
doubt it maybe it's to be a little bit
more open that's way easier than
vulnerable maybe that is the less scary
approach then
I mean yes I mean uh we we have to
attack the word vulnerable only because
it's it's in the in the vernacular right
now vulnerability is used in the
business press now I know it's all the
rage All the Rage exactly
um so yeah if you want to say we work to
be more open that's fine too you know uh
whatever works whatever works
um okay another question that uh that
came in from one of our audience members
is uh how do you ensure that your
culture continues to exist within a
company when you're going when you're
growing super quickly and many employees
are being added to your team all the
time
so hyper growth is a huge risk to
company and Company culture because very
often what we do is we take our eye off
the ball of culture because we're so
fixated on growth for some reason
there's a lot of companies that are
obsessed with Hyper growth and I don't
understand it now if it's happening
organically you know during covet a lot
of companies got lucky you know they
were standing in the right place at the
right time and they saw massive growth
by virtue of the business they were in
Peloton or Amazon for example has Zoom
yeah Zoom or if your new company sold
leggings or sweatpants you know you saw
massive massive growth uh you know um
that that's organic but companies that
are obsessed with Hyper growth to to
serve an investor Community it really
makes no sense you know there's not a
single study a total of zero articles
that say that hyper growth um is is is
good for business we have to look at
growth more like a dial I mean let's
take a a hypothetical example let's say
you're a retail operation and you want
to open 200 new shops uh by the end of
the year the problem is you're hiring so
fast that you're actually not spending
the time to train the people this goes
directly to your point about the culture
you're not inculcating them in the
culture and so what you're opening is
200 bad bad shops
um which is not good for the long-term
business so it's better to adjust the
dial and say maybe we should slow down a
little bit
um and open 30 shops this year and hire
the right people and treat them properly
and then we can adjust in the future so
I think we have to be okay with
adjusting our Ambitions so that we we we
grow properly we grow with a strong
culture we're not just obsessing the
demand which is completely
counter-intuitive if you're still in
this finite mindset but if you're going
at it from an infinite uh game point of
view then that could really yeah be very
easy to to implement
um so I was wondering is there a
post-covered new normal yet because we
seem to be we're so consumed with this
ever uh ever moving prison that when
crisis just replaces the next one here
in Europe of course where Ukraine is on
our minds a lot and then there's the
even bigger crisis of climate change how
do you create time to to reflect on
things when things are just changing all
the time and we have these big crises
coming at us
well I think you know this is one of the
things we we learned from covet you know
which is I I thought it was very funny
at the beginning of coveted people said
in these uncertain times you know
there's never been a certain time not
once in history right um there's been
stability but there's never been
certainty
um and so uh you know I think what kova
did was reminded us that that nothing is
certain that we have to be prepared for
it
um and you're right I do not think
there's a new normal yet I think we are
still in a massive state of flux
um and there's still a lot of people you
know giving their predictions about the
future of work looks like we're going to
be all virtual we're going to go back to
work 100 you know I think one thing we
can safely say is going to be some sort
of Blended model with a lot more
flexibility that's not the only thing I
think we can safely predict
um but until then I think I think it's a
it's a it's it's managing uncertainty
right now yeah
um uh and and I think companies that are
staking a claim as to the kind of
cultures they want to build we'll have
will have an advantage because they're
taking bets
um but it's uh but it's a little too
soon to tell what the what the future
will look like and as you said it seems
to be crisis after unpredictable crisis
after unpredictable crisis and things
like climate change you know the
question is can we get our hands around
it yeah oh my god
um thank you for not flying here
although I would have loved to meet you
in person
um we love to bite-size stuff at uh
business boost so maybe to close it off
because I can't believe we're just
flying through this time can you share
three tangible takeaways that people can
use right away
well like we said I want to go back to
where the arrival that is the easiest
one of all the infinite minded practices
to implement which is the other leaders
sometimes in your own team the other
people in your own team uh other
companies
um that make you slightly uncomfortable
or slightly angry when their name comes
up you know what is their strength what
is something they do
um that highlights a weakness that you
can focus on that one's really easy and
tangible uh to do
um I think uh other things is is start a
book club you know a lot of companies
tell me they can't afford or they don't
have time to implement leadership
training
um and I always say nonsense you can
afford to start a book club you know
pick a book that you want to read ask
you know make don't make it mandatory
make it voluntary that every Friday
we're going to review a chapter or two
and talk about it over lunch or whatever
um and that's called leadership training
and you can pick books that highlight
skills that you want to teach whether
it's purpose or whether it's listening
or whether whatever it is but please
please please start some sort of
leadership training and the third one is
take yourself on which is try to be the
leader you wish you had you know we
can't ask our people to do things if
we're not willing to do them ourselves
lead by example
thank you so much Simon and I would add
to that uh listen to a bit of optimism
the podcast is that your British
background shining through because it's
just a bit of optimism that is so
Un-American because they would want a
lot of optimism yeah exactly uh American
would be overwhelming you with optimism
exactly um yeah it's like America we
have the belief that you know if a glass
of wine per day is good for you then a
bottle of wine must be great for you
uh so yeah no it's it's a bit of
optimism uh I think maybe it's it's just
maybe it is my English in Australia
showing through well I absolutely love
that podcast so thank you for making it
and I hope you'll continue to do so and
I hope that you will come to the
Netherlands and you'll let me take you
out to dinner because that would be
absolutely wonderful it's such a
pleasure to talk with you Simon
thank you so much thanks for having me
uh take care of yourself and take care
of each other and hopefully I'll see you
in in the Netherlands real soon